Mark individual question for you I've
asked you this I think for like 17 years
will I ever see you in the six billion
dollar man you know what I think there
is finally hope for that to happen and I
think it's kind of uh actually to a lot
to do with this movie because hopefully
sky dance will have the rights if not
fully buttoned up now very soon and uh
we'll FastTrack that movie to get made
so wow still not out of the fight I'm
still grinding every day to get it made
um you know it's uh it's tough to get
get certain things made it's very
difficult it's always an uphill battle
but I think certain ones are worth just
uh seeing through till the end listen to
me that's a no-brainer movie has it been
a rights issue or has it been just a
like it well it is now I mean we had the
rights and we were trying to get the
script right at Warners and then you
know uh people have the TV rights you
you have the estate and then you have I
think Universal had the international
and lots of things so now to kind of
bring it out uh free and clear to be
able to kind of work out all those
different issues and then uh be able to
start fresh with uh with a new writer um
at Sky dance but I'm excited because
nobody does Action better than uh David
and everybody and Dane and those guys at
Sky dance so couldn't be more excited
about the possibility yeah the one thing
I I David Ellison is I've spoken to him
a number of times he really loves movies
he really does he does yeah you know
100%